hello there today we'll look at glide
towards photorealistic image generation
and editing with text guided diffusion
models by alex nicole prafulla dariwal
aditeromesh and others of openai this
paper on a high level well i'll just
show you what you can do i'm sure you've
all seen this paper in one way or
another it is another paper that
generates images given a piece of text
but this time it's not again or anything
like this or a vq vae this time it is a
diffusion model this is a different
class of models and we'll go into what
they are and how they work but
essentially you can see right here that
the model that turns out of this and of
course this being open ai they train
this on a massive scale and this model
is really big but what comes out of it
is
very very very much better than for
example dali which al always had this
this kind of uh blurriness to it
you can see right here a crayon drawing
of a space elevator uh pixel art corgi
pizza so this is trained on a big scrape
of images from the internet and as you
can see the outputs are pretty stunning
so it gets for example the shadows right
here it gets them correctly even the red
on blue blending
it gets different styles like the the
salvador dali style
it
combines different concepts although
maybe you know this has been seen on the
internet somewhere but it is able to
combine different concepts and given
that these are diffusion models you can
actually do
a bunch of more stuff with them for
example in painting is immediately
accessible
to this model now usually in painting is
accessible to diffusion models however
they actually train an in-painting model
on top of this
but in essence a lot of stuff would be
accessible so this is now possible where
you say okay i only want to change a
part of the image like this part right
here you give a text saying a man
wearing a white hat and the model
generates the man wearing a white hat
this is
very cool you can do things like this
where you first so the pictures here are
a bit confusing but you first generate
an image from a text prompt like a cozy
living room then you get this living
room and then here the user would
annotate this window sort of would draw
over it and we'll give the next text
prompt and the next text point would be
a painting of a corgi on the wall above
the couch
and the model it's an in so this is the
in painting mode the model would only be
able to paint the green area so it would
sort of try to conform to the text
using only the green area and therefore
it would make this corgi picture on the
wall right here then the user goes
further and says well now i'm going to
paint this area right here and i'm going
to issue the prompt around coffee table
in front of a couch and the model will
generate it and so on you can see that
this enables sort of an interactive
creation of these scenery at the end
the couch
the couch in the corner of the room so
changing the entire wall right here you
can see the back of the room has some
space and now it's being changed to a
wall
so this is the kind of stuff that's
possible editing right here um
even what's this this sort of sketch
editing where you don't only mask but
along with the mask you provide sort of
like a sketch as you can see right here
so this part here is blue and then the
part here is white
and that's also
the mask
that the
picture receives and you can see
that only one cloud in the sky today it
sort of
you can guide even more so you can guide
with text and you can guide with sketch
color and so on
so this is a
very very
very cool
model you can see the quality is very
very good here is for example a
comparison these are real images from
the ms ms marco data set ms coco sorry
this is a data set of pictures with
associated labels so text descriptions
of the picture so you have some ground
truth so the ground truth here will be
this one and the label is a green train
coming down the tracks you can see dali
uh generates something neat but
it's sort of blurry it's kind of
cartoonish as all the dali pictures are
if you look in this row
the last one's pretty good but all the
other ones are sort of
elephants are more like blobs
and we've seen this in the in the dali
paper it was impressive at the time but
this is way more impressive and then
their best model this clip sorry this
glide
model with classifier free guidance you
can see right here it generates like a
high quality train
that fits the image description
and you can see in the entire in the
entire row right here it's pretty good
at doing that so there are a lot of
components to this model and we're going
to explore them a little bit
openai has released in classic open ai
fashion they've released like a small
very filtered version of that model
because they're worried about safety
like anyone's going to believe them
after gpt too they've just been doing
this every single model right they're
just like oh no safety people can make
deep fakes oh no
like
no one's made a deep fake
like gpt too all the worries they were
just not true no one has used gpt2 to
spread around fake news
and no one like no one's going to use
this model substantially to make
very misleading pictures
but we'll get to that as well
all right so what is a diffusion model
and that's sort of at the core of this
thing right here uh the diffusion model
is a different type of generative model
than maybe you're used to from like a
gan or
a vq vae so in a gan again is probably
the closest right here so again it's
sort of like a neural network with a
bunch of layers and what you do is you
sample from some sort of a distribution
you sample some noise right you sample
some noise you get some noise vector so
here is a vector which is complete noise
every entry is noise
uh you put it through the network the
network generates pretty picture
and you train the model using a
discriminator in this case you train the
model to produce pretty pictures given
the noise and the noise acts sort of as
a source of randomness um
so the mapping is clear you train to map
from noise to picture
now a diffusion model goes in almost
like a a different direction so
what you do is during training you have
a data set and you take an image so from
from a data set
you you have a data set you take an
image out of it
let's say this is your trusty trusty cat
ta-da
and
you're going to
put noise onto this image so you're
going to
add noise and noise let's represent that
with sigma nah i think they do they do
epsilon or ada
in this in this paper right here so you
add that and then you get a slightly
noisy version of this let's just uh
let's just wiggle a bit
wiggle wiggle wiggle
and you do it again so
through adding noise and you add lots
and lots and lots of noise okay so every
time you add a tiny tiny bit of noise
and that means that more and more your
picture is just going to be blurry and
blurry and blurry
now if you do this for long enough in
the limit
you can prove that obviously if you do
this infinitely many times what comes
out at the end is going to be
just
normally distributed if your noise is
normally distributed and you scale every
time correctly um then
whatever turns out is going to be
normally distributed with some
parameters here so this right here
is going to be a known distribution if
you
if you add noise for long enough if you
destroy all of the information that the
picture has then
uh you'll end up with sort of
an entry in a known distribution
however every step that you do right
here is very small every step you just
add a little bit of noise so technically
it's possible for a model to look at
this picture right here which is kind of
a bit of a blurry version of the cat and
predict and learn to predict the more
sharp version of the cat okay this is a
foundation of many many sort of
denoising models many up-sampling models
super resolution models what have you
okay they do this in one step but
essentially here we say the individual
step
is small enough such that the model
can technically learn to reconstruct it
however if we do it for long enough in
you know going to infinity the
we are at a known distribution namely
the the standard normal distribution
and these two things together mean that
well if we have trained the model to
reconstruct the individual steps what we
can technically do is we can now go
ahead sample from this known
distribution right because ultimately we
want to sample from the data
distribution but that's hard because we
don't know it but here we can just
sample some noise from a known
distribution then put it through this
process of reconstruction all the way
all the steps that we did up here during
training
during training we just noise the noise
and noise the images again and again and
again we trained the neural network to
to for every step to reconstruct the
previous step so we can now just put it
through this series of trained neural
networks in fact it's just going to be
one neural network that gets the
uh index of the step as a parameter and
out comes an image right out comes a
true data image
if these two things up here hold then
this should be possible this is the
basis for these diffusion models so
specifically um
given a sample that's what they say here
given a sample from the data
distribution
this is x0 so this is the data
we produce a markov chain of latent
variables x1 to xt
with everyone being a more noisy version
and xt finally being of a like a known
distribution because we do it infinitely
or a large number of times
by progressively adding gaussian noise
to the sample
so you can see right here we take
x t minus one we scale it down a bit
because if you wouldn't do that the sort
of the the image would just increase in
scale over because we just keep adding
stuff uh but this it's just a rescaling
there's nothing more happening here
so we
we add noise this here is the mean
of a distribution the
covariance matrix here is a diagonal
which essentially means we just add a
bit of noise of the scale
of alpha t
no sorry we just add a bit of noise we
rescale by alpha t which is a scaling
factor
and that's how we obtain the next step
the x t
so again we do this enough
so we take x t for the next step we plug
it in here
and then we obtain x t plus 1 and so on
so if the magnitude of the noise added
at each step is small enough the
posterior is well
well approximated by a diagonal gaussian
that's what they say right here so what
does this mean the posterior it means
that this is the reverse step right i
have x t and i'm looking to recreate x t
minus 1.
so if the noise is small enough then
the posterior is well approximated by a
diagonal gaussian and we have a hope to
learn it with a neural network right
furthermore if the magnitude of the
total noise added throughout the chain
is large enough
then the last step is well approximated
by a known by a standard normal
distribution these properties suggest
learning a model for this posterior
right we have x t we want to reconstruct
x t minus one to approximate the true
posterior
okay so we are going to learn a neural
network that it doesn't exactly
reconstruct the image but this is a
variational model so what we're going to
do is we're going to plug in xt into a
neural network the neural network is
going to predict the mean and the
covariance matrix of the next step up
the chain of the the next step of the
denoising chain
and then we can use this to produce
samples we simply
um sorry we start
we start with
gaussian noise which is the end and we
gradually reduce the noise in a sequence
of steps until we are at the data
distribution or at least the predicted
data distribution
so this is not a new idea this has been
and i think i have the references open
this has been explored previously for
example this just an example right here
denoising diffusion probabilistic models
is one of the papers that introduced
lots of these things you can see right
here
these have still been trained on like
just
images as such so this is the left is
trained on a face data set the right is
trained on c410 this is unconditional
generation without a text prompt or
anything like this but you can see the
same principle applies we simply
add noise during training and we learn a
neural network to remove the noise to
predict what the image would look like
one noise step less
the here already
there was
an invention that the paper here would
make use of namely the loss function
right here we're going to look at that
in just a second
oh that's that's the second
so they say well there exists a
tractable variation a lower bound better
results arise from optimizing a
surrogate objective which re-weighs the
term in the variational lower bound so
the loss we're going to optimize right
here is
during training
if you can see right here what during
training
we
we train the neural network to
reconstruct one of these steps right
each sample in training is going to be
some image
x
t minus one and some image x t and we're
going to reconstruct we're going to
train the neural network to predict
x t minus one from x t or the the
variational sort of the distribution of
that
so this is a training sample now how do
we get the training sample what we can
do is we can take x0 right here and we
could go through and add and add and add
noise but since we always add gaussian
noise
we can simply do this in one step
there's nothing depending intermediately
right here so we do it in one step right
here and then we add another bit of
noise that's how we get the two samples
and then rather than predicting the
image itself what these models do is
they will predict the noise so what we
actually predict is going to be the
noise
the noise epsilon here which we can
calculate by x t minus x t minus 1.
so this is our prediction target this is
our
loss function the network is supposed to
output this right here
and
of course we know the true one
you can see the network will try to
output this given
x t and an index into which step it is
so we're going to tell the network by
the way
here's the noise
here is the number of steps we're into
this process
and we're going to train the network to
re to
say
what was the noise that was added it's a
bit easier just i think it's just like a
scaling scaling property because this is
going to have sort of zero mean
and uh unit variance so it's easier to
predict for a neural network
so that is one of
that is um very standard in diffusion
models
the next
thing uh
they introduce is guided diffusion
by the way they also mentioned somewhere
that they they learn the
covariance matrix yes there's another
paper that
also learns the covariance matrix this
first paper just fixed it at a diagonal
but then there is another paper that
improved upon that uh called improved
denoising diffusion probabilistic model
interestingly by
the same authors here and
uh they
they show a method to learn this
covariance matrix which is mostly a
scaling issue
because there's a narrow band that is a
valid covariance matrix
and they show up with the correct
parameterization they can in fact learn
it and and get better
better performance but this is just for
reference it's not super important right
here
the second part is
more important so this is guided
diffusion
so what we can do here is we can build
a model let's just assume we have images
and we have class labels for the images
let's leave away the text right now okay
so we have a class label
four here so this has a class label of
cat for example there's also dog and so
on so what we can do is we can train the
neural network here you know each step
we train it to reconstruct one step so
that's going to predict the noise that
was added given the image x t given the
index t what we can also do is we can
say by the way it's also we give it the
label y so y in this case is cat
so we can train a class conditional
model and that you know has some
some advantages we know class
conditional gains work quite well so if
you give it the class label as an input
you can often
improve that and you would do that by
either
embedding the class label as a one-hot
vector into the network or something
like this now with the text model it's a
bit more tricky right but what you can
do is you let's say this here
this here is some sort of a neural
network right so xt goes in this is xt
uh goes into
an encoder with a bunch of layers maybe
the t
itself also goes in here as some sort of
a float or an embedding a one hot vector
or something like this
and the class label could also go in
here right however if you have text um
what you can do
is let's say you don't have this but now
you have a text description they call
this c
so you can first put the text
description to through
its own network
and then combine the embeddings so
either put the embeddings here as sort
of a class embedding or you can put the
embeddings into each layer
right here in this stack and i think
they do both
in any case you can
embed
the text
right here
of the image
because their data set always has images
and text together so that's what i said
at the beginning
so you can take this
text you can put it through an encoder
itself you can input it into this
process right here this is the network
that is going to ultimately predict the
added noise
given an image
and yeah the network can take
inspiration and take can learn from the
text so if it sees this picture right
here for example
but in a very noisy way and it has the
text information a couch in the corner
of a room it's obviously going to
perform better than if it wouldn't have
the text and ultimately that's going to
unlock the capability that we can input
a text at the very beginning and then
the model guided by this text will
produce a living room sorry a couch in
the corner of a room
so now
is this enough and the answer is not
yet
so
uh
class conditional models are working
fine however
it's better if you do what's called
guided diffusion so in guided diffusion
we not only want to make our models
class conditional
but we want to we want to
guide them even more we want to push
them into a direction and this is called
guided diffusion and one way to do it is
to say well i have a an additional
classifier
i have a classifier
for example
an imagenet classifier right and if i
want to push my diffusion process
towards a particular label i can take
that imagenet classifier and i can go
along the gradient
of that this is very much like things
like deep dreamwork or
this is essentially clip clip guided
diffusion
is this but with clip
so i have the clip model and if you
don't know what the clip model is this
is a model where you input an image
and a piece of text
and it tells you how good
how good do the so
let's put that as sigmoid is do these
two things fit together well or not
now if you think about the gradient of
this with respect to the image
then you can
see that you can push
the diffusion process
into a direction
where the image would fit together with
the text more because you go along the
gradient of that it's kind of you
construct an adversarial example towards
this classifier
so this is one way of doing it but it
means that you have to have some sort of
an external uh classifier to go by there
is also a method called classifier free
guidance and this was introduced by
hoenn solomons
and this is where you
sort of use the model's
own knowledge about its class
conditioning in order to do
this guidance and this is a bit weird
and i feel like i feel like
i feel like this shouldn't really work
and i feel the fact that this works
appears to be a little bit of just a
hint that our current models aren't
making use of the data fully because we
have to do these tricks at inference
time so
it's more pointing towards us not really
being the masters of these technologies
yet uh rather than this being some sort
of an intrinsically good thing to do but
essentially what we want to do is
during training we train these class
conditional things right we train let's
produce the noise
that was added to x t in the last step
conditioned on y and y here could be a
class label y could be the input text
what could be you know pretty much any
conditioning information
and then
every we also alongside that sometimes
we don't provide that label at all
we don't just don't provide the label
which essentially means that we are
training an unconditional generator so
we just simply forget the fact that we
have labels we simply train the image
generation model unconditional
so
we just give the model xt we ask there
was just some image without description
without nothing what was the noise added
to this image
and now at inference so we just train
the model in both ways during training
we sometimes just leave away the label
this could be beneficial as this part in
fact would be the opportunity to bring
more data into the picture right let's
say i have only part of my data is
labeled and part of my data is only
unlabeled
we could actually in here bring in the
unlabeled data and therefore get more
data into the system than we usually had
but given that they probably have enough
data with their giant image caption
data set here
by the way it's the same data set they
used for dali
given that it's probably they just leave
away the text at during during training
for some of the they say right here with
another label with a fixed probability
during training
now during inference you can do
something with that what you can do
during inference you can say well if i
am in the situation where i have an
image and a label and i ask my model to
generate
the noise what i can do is i can do a
little bit like the same thing i did
with the clip guiding
so here i let my model predict
the
unnoised version
but i also push it into the direction
that clip tells me would be a good image
right so it's two things this says given
the image what would be the unnoisy or
the less noisy version and this one
would be well in general which image
would be sort of appropriate for this
piece of text
you mix the two objectives this is very
much the same
so
if you unpack this you can see that this
right here
unconditionally asks given this image
which is the less noisy version of the
image
or give me the noise that is at was
added to the image
and then you push it into this direction
right here and you can see this is the
difference between
the noise
that the model predicts unconditionally
and the noise that the model predicts
conditioned on the label
so this is a direction
this direction
points very much into the direction of
the noise that we specifically added to
the label right so it's the difference
between the conditional and
unconditional prediction we add that
to the predicted noise right here
so the the model predicts okay
this is the noise that was added
and the the conditional model predicts
this one and then we simply push
the prediction into this direction
you can see right here there's a scalar
s involved s obviously must be larger
than one
because if s is smaller like
this is what we would predict usually
the conditional one
so now if s is larger than one we're
going to predict uh something more
up here
and notice the difference if we didn't
have this if we didn't have this we
would simply predict this point right
here we wouldn't know which one which
direction was a better direction because
we also have the unconditional point
right here we can clearly say that this
direction is probably the direction that
goes into
into the direction of the conditioning
information so we can choose to sort of
overdo it
again i think that is
that's kind of a trick
around the fact that we don't know
we don't know
how to handle the information uh very
well quite yet
i'm not sure but
um it seems like you wouldn't even have
to
seems like you wouldn't even have to do
this necessarily what you could also do
if you want to go further you could take
sort of inspiration from uh the
contrastive learning communities and
maybe do some heart some you could also
replace this part and and this part by
the way so these parts you could replace
sort of by an expectation of these
noises over some
labels y hat or y prime so
which means you could just sample some
other text or some other conditioning
information randomly and
get an expectation you could also do
hard negative sampling so you could take
labels that are fairly close or you
could take labels that are kind of
confusing and
try to differentiate yourself there's a
lot of possibilities here i can see that
but still it feels like a bit of a trick
yeah so
good that's what they do
they do clip guidance so they do this
classifier free guidance which turns out
to be the better variant and they also
do the clip guidance which is what we
discussed before except with clip you
can see they've just replaced the
gradient of a classifier with the
gradient of the clip model the clip
model
is simply an inner product between an
embedding of the image and embedding of
the text
and they say the reason probably that
the classifier free guidance works
better is because
uh the clip mod
sort of the diffusion models what they
do is they find like adversarial
examples to clip and not necessarily
good
pictures
now i don't know if the classifier-free
guidance would also be something that
could replace sort of the the current
notebooks that are flying around where
clip is used clip guided uh diffusion
and vq vq gan plus clip
but i'm not sure because the vq gan it
seems already restricts
the
already restricts the space of images
such that it's not that easy to find uh
adversarial examples because it always
has to go through the vector
quantization
okay that's the model like
the model is nothing else it's a
diffusion model all right this has
existed before
it is conditioned on conditioning
information the diffusion model itself
is conditioned in this case on text that
goes through a transformer encoder which
is the blue thing right here this
embeddings are then sort of concatenated
into the process of this diffusion model
the diffusion model is
a model that for one of these steps
predicts
sort of tries to predict the reverse
it's the same model for each step it
just gets as an additional conditioning
information which step it's currently
trying to reconstruct it always
reconstructs the noise that was added
training data generation is pretty easy
you simply add noise to an image and
then you add a bit more and then the
difference between that is the target to
predict
um
then at inference time at inference time
they also do this guided diffusion
right that's either going to be achieved
by clip
and the disadvantage of that is that you
have to have an additional classifier
like clip not only that but in fact the
classifier has also have been trained on
noisy images
because otherwise noisy images are going
to be out of its distribution so they do
in fact train noise clip versions
the disadvantage as i said is you need
this additional model that's trained on
noisy data the advantage is that you get
to bring additional information here you
get to essentially potentially even
bring additional data sets that was used
uh to train these other classifiers you
can use multiple classifiers whatever
they also do classifier free guidance
these two things
they don't use them together clip
guidance and classifier free they use
them either or
the classifier free guidance is more
like a hack
where you alongside the conditional
denoising train and unconditional
denoising so you train the model also to
sometimes not be conditioned and then
you push it
into direction away from the
unconditioned towards the conditioned
and beyond
to make it
extra conditioned i guess
the disadvantage here is that it seems
like a hack
the advantage is that there's potential
maybe to do
some some horror negative sampling and
also it doesn't require an extra model
on the side and also in the
unconditional
training you might bring in additional
data that has no label
so training happens
uh
it's a 3.5 billion parameter a text
conditional diffusion model at 64 by 64
resolution this is way smaller than dali
by the way and this is this is cool
um and a 1.5 billion parameter text
conditional up sampling diffusion model
to increase the resolution so it's a
two-stage process
the diffusion model itself is at a 64 by
64 resolution and then they have an up
sampling models it's also text
conditional
but it is an
so this is purely a diffusion up
sampling model it's very much the same
principle
except that uh it now doesn't go it
doesn't go from
noisy image or sorry from from pure
noise to image it goes from low
resolution image to high resolution
image
and alongside of that they train uh a
noised clip model which is the
classifier that they're gonna need to do
guidance
um well they describe here
a little bit of the architectures we're
not super interested at least i'm not
super interested in the architectures
they're way big models as i said they
release the small models they don't
release the big models and they
explicitly train for in-painting even
though you could do it with diffusion
models without
training but they say if you train it it
uh
it it it behaves a bit better so during
training they would sort of mask out
random parts of the images and then uh
use diffusion to reconstruct those
and yeah the results are the results
that we've already seen this these are
pretty interesting they do studies with
it so they do studies on these data sets
um so as they increase the guidance
scales uh they
the guidance scales are like the only
thing the only handle they have at
inference time um that to trade off
to trade off um diversity and sort of uh
adherence to the data set
and it turns out that the classifier
free guidance as you can see right here
is is behaving better this this be the
the frontier right here these always
trade off two
two different uh metrics in the ms cocoa
dataset here precision recall here
inception score and fid
and you can see the only time the clip
guidance is better than classifier free
guidance is when you directly look at
the clip score that's why they say
probably the clip guidance simply finds
adversarial examples
towards clip they also let humans rate
the pictures in terms of photorealism
and caption similarity and you can see
that the
free guidance wins both times
and that's pretty much it they show some
failure cases which i also find pretty
interesting
so
an illustration of a cat that has eight
legs uh is is not not a thing
bicycle that has continuous tracks
instead of wheels it seemed like it
seemed a bit like dali
as a model was more sort of sensitive or
was more respondent to uh to to text
itself so to the to the prompt whereas
here it seems it's more like generating
realistic images that has some sort of
the the words
so the words kind of match with the text
a mouse hunting a lime not happening
also a car with triangular wheels
also not happening as you can see i
myself have tried the small model a
little bit and you can
see
[Music]
you can you can try it yourself i'll put
a link a link up there is a a radio
space uh by the user valhalla thanks a
lot for creating that so here is balloon
race you can see
um that works pretty well a drawing of a
tiny house that's also okay a hidden
treasure on a tropical island and i mean
it's a tropical island right but
yeah
all the elephants had left a long time
ago now only a few vultures remain and
it's just kind of a bunch of elephants
so well the elephants are kind of
walking away a little bit right
yeah um
attention is all you need obviously
oddly russian uh
russian vibes from this picture
and this one is glory to the party and
uh
i guess party is just it's just sort of
equated with with birthday cake or so
so uh
the the sort of text sensitivity of this
model might not be as as good um but
there might be opportunity to fiddle
here uh the the samples as such they
look they look pretty pretty cool it's
also not clear how much of a difference
this is between the small model and the
large model or how much effort into
diffusion is put they also
say they they they release the
the model they release is sort of a
model on a filtered version of a data
set and the filtered version removes for
example
um
removes hate symbols and anything to do
with people so they say it's not as easy
to generate deep fakes
uh yeah
and
where was
yeah i think the the coolest one is
where you can do this interactively
that is that is a pretty cool one i want
to look at lastly where sorry for the
scrolling around safety consideration so
there's so like
they say
as a result releasing our model without
safeguards
would significantly reduce skills
required to create convincing
disinformation or deep fakes
and they say
they only release the small model they
say this somewhere
where is it
well in any case they only release a
small model but i just want everyone to
remember gpt2 and uh
it was exactly the same and to my
knowledge cheap there there's not
the world is not in chaos right now
because people have used gpt2 which is
sort of public by now and can be easily
trained by anyone the world is not in
chaos because
people have access to gpt too
it's it's not the case
and i don't know why they do it because
for pr reasons or because they want to
kind of sell it sell the larger model
sell access to it i mean that's all fine
but don't tell me this is safety
considerations and yeah the fact is
people are going to create
deep fakes in the future it's going to
be easier
but it's kind of we have to
the answer is not to not release the
models and techniques the answer is to
educate people that hey look
not everything you see on a on a picture
especially if it looks like it's up
sampled from two from 64 by 64
not everything you see on there might be
entirely real right um
things can be altered things can be
photoshopped things can be
created like this uh
it's the same as people have learned
that not everything that's written in an
email
is true
and people will simply have to to adapt
that's going to be the only way
not giving people access to these things
seems to be kind of futile but as i said
i i don't believe
for a second that actual safety
considerations were uh the reason for
this
in any case let me know what you think
and that was it from me uh try try out
the model
and maybe you'll find something cool
bye-bye